I dropped out of college Christian music
and I know you always say like people
always think they're like hard on
themselves because other people say to
them but I don't really get that like
most people you're hard on your own self
and I really don't get hate or anything
yeah the music I make and stuff it's
almost like maybe I feel like they're
just not truthful but for someone
they're trying to be nice yeah of course
that's but but that's other people's
voices what most people understand is
they're boys talking to themselves it
was a voice they took from others along
the way and made it theirs the reason I
believe in everything is because my
mom's voice was the only voice I
listened to and she told me all along
the way that I could you need to realize
that's true that the voice that's saying
to you you're not as good as they're
saying that's a lie it's a lie your head
your voice does think you can do it the
voice you're listening to was the one
that was implanted from zero to seven or
at four or two or nine you know maybe
from your parents maybe from some other
direction but it's not true